إن جاني صالحي من أوماها نبراسكا أنانية للغاية وغير محترمة ،
وهي واحدة من
ملايين الأمريكيين الذين
سُرقوا حزم عطلاتهم من باب منزلهم الأمامي ،
ورأينا أن الرجل ظهر
بصندوق فارغ كشرك أعتقد أنه حاول
أن يبدو وكأنه توصيل  الرجل
ثم سارع بعيدًا مع ثلاث
طرود أخرى ، التقطت كاميرا باب جارها أيضًا
اللص وسائقه
في مكان قريب من كاميرا جار آخر
التقطت هذا الشخص وهو يرتدي ملابس
وردية يسرق هدايا العيد من
شرفته أيضًا في جميع أنحاء البلاد.
تدمر
عطلات العائلات في شريفبورت
لويزيانا ، تقول هذه المرأة إن منزلها
استُهدف مرتين ، مما جعلني أشعر بالانتهاك
في صب واي لأن هذه هي المرة الأولى
التي يحدث فيها هذا لي شخصيًا في
فريسنو كاليفورنيا ، وهو قرصان
في الشرفة يرتدي شجيرات حمراء في عيد الميلاد
للحصول على الهدايا  كنا في الخارج للعمل ومن
ثم يأتي شخص ما ويأخذ حوالي 250
قطعة منا وهو أمر
مزعج للغاية جنوب هناك
اتصل بيكرسفيلد بكاميرا جرس الباب هذه المرأة
تسرق هدايا العائلة في الثالثة
صباحًا ، إنه منزلك
في الفيديو وترى فقط شخصًا
يأخذ عقارك ، لذا لا إنه ليس
شعورًا جيدًا على الإطلاق وفقًا
لمورد آمن عبر الإنترنت للسلامة
و Security porch Pirates سرقوا
ما لا يقل عن 260 مليون طرد في
الاثني عشر شهرًا الماضية معظمها في موسم العطلات
، القيمة المقدرة لتلك
الحزم التي تقارب 20 مليار دولار
يمكن أن يكون قراصنة الشرفات أذكياء جدًا ، حيث ورد أن البعض
يرتدون زي سائقي توصيل أمازون
لكن الشرطة تزداد ذكاء
أيضًا في كامبل ، تضع شرطة كاليفورنيا
أجهزة GPS في ما يسمى بحزم
الطعم لتعقب اللصوص
وبعض مالكي المنازل يدخلون إليها
أيضًا مثل معاطف مات من بورتلاند الذي
جاء مع كلبه مارلو
بمفاجأة كريهة للشرفة  كان لدى القراصنة في
منطقتهم شيئًا ما يختفي من الشرفة ،
كان الأمر محبطًا حقًا لذلك اعتقدت أنه من
المحتمل  حدث ذلك مرة أخرى ،
لذا ملأت صندوقًا مليئًا ببراز الكلاب
المعبأ بالكامل ، وتركته على الشرفة بعد
ثلاثة أيام ، اختفى الصندوق النتن ،
وتم القبض على اللص أمام الكاميرا
وفي مفاجأة كبيرة يا فتى طيب
[موسيقى]
ثم هناك مارك  روبرت روبرت ،
مهندس ناسا السابق الذي صنع قنبلة لامعة
لردع اللصوص عندما يتم
فتح العبوات بخاخات لامعة في كل مكان
ولكن فقط عندما كنت تعتقد أن غرينش
سوف يفسد عيد الميلاد
، تغير موقف بعض قراصنة الشرفة في هيوستن
بعد هذه المرأة البالغة من العمر 19 عامًا و
يُزعم أن آخرين سرقوا الطرود التي
أعادوها لهم ، جعلهم آباؤهم
كما لو كنت لا تتوقع أن يسرق شخص ما
شيئًا منك ويعيده
لم يفت الأوان أبدًا على
فرحة عيد الميلاد الصغيرة راندي ك.سي إن إن بالم بيتش
فلوريدا